i'm jim wallace and here at Davos many
people are understanding them underneath
the economic crisis is the values crisis
we won't get to an economic recovery
without a more recovery shaping at a
moral compass for the new economy so
we've been having sessions here and in
previous years if you wanted to talk
about social conscience social values of
Davos you had to get up at 7am and go to
the fourth floor and you hear people
like me and Muhammad Yunus talk about
this but on the first day of da most
Muhammad and I were on main floor
talking about the need for social
business or social conscience for
purposeful economies that for a moral
economy and many people are very
receptive to that yet we've been
overtaken by these new Maxim's greed is
good it's all about me and I want it now
we have to replace those missile an
older virtues like enough is enough
we're in this together and i love the
indigenous peoples ethic and evaluate
decisions today by their impact on the
seventh generation out so we talked
about the bad morality play of banks and
bailouts and bonuses and how the massive
bank bonuses in the face of massive
economic suffering is in my language a
sin of biblical proportions and how
people are moving their money from the
big banks to local banks and we say the
banks getting too big to fail we say
make them smaller so people are talking
about citizens movements down to bring
values back in this conversation I've
just written the book called Rick
rediscovering values and Wall Street
Main Street in your stream and we had to
launch the book last night and I've been
pleased by the conversation between
business leaders labor leaders community
organizers religious leaders and lots
and lots of young people so it's a new
conversation now we have the discussion
on Jon Stewart last Wednesday night I
think
ready now for a new conversation bags if
we don't have that all the suffering
pain this recession will have been in
vain but if we have a values
conversation may be a great recession
could be redemptive after all I hope so